nikto fobia il demonio incazzato non
credo che stiamo parlando di nintendo se
però non si può mai sapere con un bel e
adulti ragazzi e benvenute questo nuovo
video sono file è oggi siamo sui un nick
povia è appunto il demone incazzato 6
gioco
parquet l'audio già fa metà del gioco
due menu porca vacca stagione veramente
fatto bene solitari games giochi la
solità da e sicuramente non lo gioco coi
miei amici questo 21 dicembre 2015
quattro giorni prima di natale grazie
per averlo specificato che la matematica
non la so benissimo il giorno che ho
deciso di entrare in questo misterioso
manicomio
zio dei neuroni bravo così si fa così si
vive no mica ti devi fare i cazzi tuoi a
natale vai a fare in cui aveva comunque
decisioni discutibili a parte vediamo
questo manicomio che cosa ci offre a
michelin quindi neanche il mifi ci fa
ritrovare dentro io devo prendere quella
stupida decisione di andarci organi
sembra giusto e una torcia che ci
aspetta lì della serie trentini [ __ ]
che vive la tua giornata nel peggiore
dei modi va bene eccoci qua penn di
tutte le luci va bene che non si
risparmiano energia ca spegnete le luci
come usate
è un gioco anche educativo questo mi fa
piacere il problema non è tanto questo
il problema è che cazzo mi fai parquet
intro è cos'è sa cosa vuol dire c'è una
scatola in ict
non stavo scherzavo parlando del vino
della scala non volevo offendere nessuno
e volevo solo uscire di casa quello il
mio cesso
ancora non sono andate nei posti ok
da un altro va beh devo aspettare cosa
era quello di sicuro non era tua suocera
però un po ci somigliavano compagno ma
adesso ho capito perché sensi ha dato
nel manicomio perché in com'era il
confronto era un posto tranquillo basta
andare in un posto tranquillo quando ci
sono la rispettano quindi quando avete
satana in casa andate nei manicomi
sembra giusto si prospetta forse più di
un video happy di un video in cui
gioiremo di vivere soprattutto io sono
arrivato questo post è krypi come
l'inferno
che cazzo ti aspettavi che ti aspettavi
la casa delle barbie è certo obiettivo
trova la tua via per il manicomio grazie
aver messo il sound effect di satana
perché solo perché sono sceso dalla
macchina del fido grazie di indicarmi la
via ma che bel posto per fare campeggio
coi tecnici tu devi essere proprio il
ceo del divertimento zigon vedo proprio
l'ora di conoscerti
siamo entrati nel manicomio per lo zoom
in out loud ragazzi solo con la
differenza che questo qua a un neurone
spero che non sia una brutta janoskova
dare un'occhiata solo un attimo e
premeva certo ma tu si che sei proprio
confronto sia uscito tutti i blog solo
sui e non sicuramente non meno di me
perché io ho preso il minimo però quello
nato discorso cioè una camera prima non
aspetta che ho fatto
investigates dei sì sì sì
night vision
vabbè ma e c'è anche la batteria li sta
roba 9 vada avanti con questa è molto
più utile meno male che non c'era meno
male che non hanno messo la batteria nel
gioco che sarebbe stato problematico è
molto meglio che la night vision non si
vede in casa cioè un outlast arte povera
sto gioco praticamente dovunque mi
conviene andare flashlight non sarà una
sega è molto meglio così scusa dice
qualcosa bellissimo no se è un invito a
cucinare non lo faccio perché non so se
vogliamo rendere ancora più che visto
posto e dovete vedermi cucinare preso
una chiave va bene chi avesse meter c'è
un seminterrato meno male perché fino
allora tutto alle cure i posto e questo
non si capisce niente
la stanza dei pazienti è bloccata
salve facciano già la videocamera perché
quante videocamere ciao zio ma scud
no io volevo mettere a torce eccola qua
buongiorno
no attive dei piedi ed
è sparita
ah
vabbè eccolo non vedevo l'ora di entrare
nel basement ragazzi ora sì che siamo a
posto non mi piace questo posto non è
invece volevo andare qua ma intanto
riprende quella strana voglia di andare
o a gardaland ho qua e uno dei due posti
non so mai quale decidere sempre più
allegro ma è finita non c'è niente
c'è un basement veramente figo c'è una
pentola
la chiave della cucina e meno male
non vediamo l'ora di andare in cucina ma
torniamo che sicuramente non succederà
niente in questo seminterrato era
detenuto
ovviamente mi sono preso un infarto
molto più grande di quello che ho dato a
vedere perché il mio cuore sta ancora
andando avanti ai 2000 ma fa niente
meno male che il braccio gioca l'ex
lager o corri cosa
ma che cazzo è
ajo e non c'è uno scaffale sono morto
morto somma
hanno campionato i miei urli ero io che
urlavo veramente incredibile ma che
cazzo devo fare io qua la scusa è un
ceppo è la vedova dovevo andare era
chiuso amico voi in chiudo la porta in
faccia cosa è successo calmati anche
angelica si chiama sta tizia ok c'è un
nome che quindi era un sogno è un
checkpoint scusa l'hanno capito però che
cosa potevo fare niente un sogno check
point
allora è un sogno a ok sai che proprio
non so dove dovrebbe essere la cucina
penso questa
olie a non mi sembra proprio la tuscia
ma neanche a me poi fanno il brunch col
morto praticamente la bellissima che
cos'era questo suono di sicuro non sono
i tuoi neuroni che si collegano perché
non ce l'ha visto la camera dei pazienti
ue voldemort st questo qua è
tutto a posto
c'è voldemort e dell'altra
statica [ __ ] tua madre morta dei cori
che è successo
stava un tizio qua
è tutto bene raga va tutto a posto
che cazzo sto giocando scusatemi ma
evolve volti
non sta più non c'è più c'era volte
morte di fermo non ho capito il senso
provate andiamo nella stanza dei
pazienti ragazzi per ora tutto a posto
tutto allegro è un gioco fatto solo per
prendermi per il culo i jam scala
sostanziale che c'è un joker ogni 4
secondi è una roba che non ha un senso
prova bene
se si apre la stanza dei pazienti eccola
qua è veramente messa asm in chianti
sono d'accordo che traduzione cento per
cento
sacchi temur destra pur aprendo anche
perché non c'è nessuna chiave 4 dovresti
da anni una chiave fi no
così così a kami sono barricato dentro
sei
bravo [ __ ] alla togli li aiuta e
cazzo linea
ma io non so questo sto giocando la
caccia ma veramente no
no
no mi rifiuto mi rifiuto no
vado via a rivederci qui ragazzi questo
era il primo dei due episodi di nitto
folias spero vi sia piaciuto non
perdetevi il secondo perché come ciò che
è molto strano ma merita quindi niente
godetevi anche secondo episodio uscirà
tra poco io vi ringrazio per ha visto
video siete anche rai lascia un commento
mi piace e noi come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video della ragazza
[Musica]